si la contre-offensive ukrainienne a
pris de courts les troupes russes
l'étendue de son succès à tout autant
surpris ses soldats ukrainiens
on est monté à l'asso on a capturé une
position on l'a occupé on l'a fortifié
trois jours plus tard le front a avancé
et ils ont commencé à décompter par
rapport on se tenait prêt à combattre
alors imaginez qu'ils allaient quitter
tout seul l'ensemble du front ça
vraiment ne l'avait pas prévu
des soldats Ukrainiens savent à remettre
en marche le matériel abandonné par les
[Musique]
et ça va aller pour le roulement
de véhicules Oural russes qu'ils avaient
préparé pour l'invasion et bien
maintenant ils vont travailler pour nous
la déroute de l'armée russe se constate
partout ces soldats tout juste arrivé
pour sécuriser le territoire découvre
les anciennes positions russes
les lignes Russes se sont disloquées ici
ne reste que Lénine une pin-up et des
journaux de style soviétique sans
mauvaise nouvelle
l'histoire de ce succès tactique de
commandant accepte de nous en parler
leurs paroles est rare
André Malakoff est officier dans les
Forces Spéciales il a été blessé par
balle pendant l'opération selon lui
cette réussite tient d'abord à la ruse
imaginée par l'état-major ukrainien
quelques semaines avant l'offensive
j'ai dirigé l'assaut
principale était la diversion au sud de
ballakiya
en fait
la plus grosse percée s'est faite par
l'Ouest
mais le renseignement a répondu partout
l'information
que l'attaque aurait lieu au sud
ils ont donc envoyé beaucoup de troupes
au sud
a commencé
on en a tué 200
toutes leurs tentatives de
contre-attaque ont été repoussés
ils s'en souviendront longtemps
la règle dans les manuels de tactique
c'est que pour attaquer il faut être
trois fois plus nombreux que l'ennemi là
nous étions trois fois moins
une opération audacieuse basée sur une
manœuvre s'enfoncer en territoire ennemi
sur une longue distance
lorsque le plan lui est présenté il y a
roselaf va saluke a du mal à le croire
il commande une batterie de
lance-roquette multiple
donc ils nous ont brisés sur le plan et
ça nous a paru fou
il y a effectivement
partagés parce qu'il ne pouvait pas
juste avoir sorti un plan complètement
aberrant de leur chapeau
donc se devait tout de même être
réalisable
sur le papier ça pouvait être réalisé
mais c'était tellement audacieux c'était
c'était hyper cool
et quand je suis allé voir mes hommes
je leur ai dit à moitié en rigolant on
va mourir
son unité est désormais impatiente de
poursuivre cette contre-offensive
j'espère que ça va continuer
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit aussi
rapide ou que les prochaines phases
soient déclenchées dans l'immédiat
en ce qui concerne le moral l'une des
conséquences du succès de cette
contre-attaque c'est que ceux qui n'ont
pas pu y prendre part sont encore plus
motivés pour travailler dur afin d'être
choisi pour les prochaines opérations
je leur dis toujours on a encore
tellement de territoires à libérer que
tout le monde aura sa chance de
participer à la libération d'un
territoire
mais il y a déjà une sorte de
compétition entre pour être inclus dans
la suite des opérations et je crois que
cela vient du succès de cette
contre-offensive
[Musique]
dans les territoires reconquis la tâche
n'est pas tout à fait finie ces soldats
viennent tout juste d'arriver à Isio
c'est pas tranquille ici on ne sait pas
ce qui se passe dans les bois il n'y a
pas que nous ici il y en a qui se cache
on n'a pas fini le travail
des patrouilles
on nettoie les bois et les villages où
il y a encore ces
on appelle direct les services
un travail de fourmis puisque ce sont
des milliers de kilomètres de
territoires qui leur faut désormais
sécuriser